[Musique]
c'est le premier ministe bravant les
distanciation physique des marées
humaines déferlent dans le monde entier
pour dire stop aux inégalités raciales
la morge de george frey victimes de
violences policières a fait se lever
avant planétaire pour dire que lévis
noir compte cette exigence trouve un
écho puissant en france avec l'affairé
adama traoré pour qui vérité et justice
sont exigées l'impunité doit cesser
depuis longtemps les violences
policières sont une préoccupation dans
les quartiers populaires mais il a fallu
les répressions violentes des gilet
jaune pour qu'elles soient partagées au
niveau national les traitements
discriminatoires existe au sein de la
police comme au sein de la société
à la nuance près quand même que les
policiers sont détenteurs de l'autorité
publique et de la violence légitime que
certains rendent illégitime dois-je ici
rappeler toutes ces affaires sordides de
violence policière sur fond de racisme
certains ont été agressés théo hier
gabriel aujourd'hui d'autres qui ont
trouvé la mort zyed et bouna à damas
sans compter tous ceux usé de devoir
justifier leur identité parfois
plusieurs fois par jour monsieur le
premier ministre
quelles réponses structurelles comptez
vous apporter pour rompre définitivement
avec ces pratiques racistes et d'une
violence disproportionnée noter au sein
de la police j'ai un désaccord avec vous
je sais pas si j'ai un désaccord et vous
madame la présidente
mais en tout cas je ne crois pas et je
ne laisserai pas dire car ça ne
correspond pas à l'expérience que j'ai
que la police ou la gendarmerie serait
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que vous avez
dit madame la présidente
ce n'est pas ce que vous avez dit je le
dis parce que n'est pas impossible que
ma réponse dépasse les murs de cette
enceinte
ce n'est pas ce que vous avez dit je ne
peux pas laisser dire et je ne laisserai
jamais dire que la police ou la
gendarmerie serait d organisation des
institutions violentes ou raciste elles
ne sont je le dis madame la présidente
ni l'une ni l'autre ni l'une ni l'autre
la police et la gendarmerie sont des
institutions qui à la différence de
beaucoup d'autres sont extrêmement
contrôlée placé sous l'oeil vigilant des
médias de nos concitoyens des organismes
internes d'inspection et de contrôle la
police et la gendarmerie ou plus
exactement les policiers et les
gendarmes exerce des missions
redoutablement difficile vous le savez
vous le savez rester calme en toutes
circonstances appréhender les
malfaiteurs être exposés à un risque
permanent du simple fait que l'on est
dépositaire de l'autorité publique bien
souvent du simple fait que l'on porte un
uniforme et nous avons tous tous en tête
des exemples nombreux de femmes et
d'hommes
quels qu'ils soient qui ont été attaqué
et pris pour cible parce qu'ils
portaient des uniformes qui fait leur
fierté et qui est notre protection
vous avez évoqué cette période
particulière et au fond malheureuse vite
des gilet jaune et vous avez indiqué
madame la présidente que cette période
démontrerait à l'évidence des
prétendants démontrerait des violences
ou illustrerait pardon voilà vous avez
raison illustrerait des violences
policières
cette période a été violente
elle n'a pas été le fait de violence
choisie exercée par la police sur des
manifestants pacifiques
je vous le dis comme je le pense comme
je les ai vécus madame la présidente
nous avons assisté dans cette période je
n'ai pas tout le monde dans le même
panier bien entendu nous avons assisté
dans cette période à des mises en cause
à des insultes à des crachats à des
violences incroyablement intense à
l'égard des policiers et des gendarmes
l'exercice du métier de policier de
gendarme dans la société dans laquelle
nous vivons et nous pouvons regretter
que la société dans laquelle nous vivons
soit brutale et violente est difficile
et je veux dire madame la présidente la
confiance l'estiment le respect absolu
absolue que j'ai pour les femmes et les
hommes qui s'engagent pour protéger
leurs concitoyens
et c'est parce que j'ai cette estime
cette confiance ce respect que j'ai
cette exigence que vous partagez j'en
suis sûr cette exigence d'exemplarité
qui dit qu'aucun acte raciste ne peut
être tolérée dans l'absolu est peut-être
encore moins lorsqu'il est le fait de
quelqu'un qui est dépositaire de
l'autorité publique
cette exigence doit être mise en oeuvre
je ne veux pas je ne veux pas que le
débat intense et délicat de la formation
de l'explication des missions de la
police de la définition des techniques
les plus adaptées dans une société qui
devient de plus en plus violente
je ne veux pas que ce débat soit comme
confisqué par des prises de positions
théâtrale par des raccourcis ou des
amalgames que tous nous avons dénoncé et
que nous devons tous continuer à
dénoncer avec des situations qui se
déroulerait ailleurs je le dis comme je
le pense
nous devons être confiants nous devions
être respectueux nous devons être
exigeants vis-à-vis des femmes et des
hommes qui
font vivre la police nationale et la
gendarmerie et c'est cette ligne qui est
une ligne d'équilibré qui est une ligne
d'équilibré que je veux tenir mais je ne
veux pas madame la présidente que la
peur change de camp
je ne veux pas que la présomption passe
de celui qui troublent l'ordre public à
celui qui le défend parce que si nous
acceptons cette facilité de l'esprit
sous le coup de l'émotion et l'émotion
est légitime et à les grandes et les
partager mais si nous acceptons cette
facilité alors c'est un basculement de
la république qui intervient et je vous
dire mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
le basculement de la république
quand je vois cela je me dis qu'il n'est
pas si loin alors je vous propose madame
la présidente d'être ensemble exigeant
avec les femmes et les hommes qui
composent la police nationale et la
gendarmerie
et de ce point de vue là nous sommes
d'accord mais que nous leur disions
parce que ici au sénat on est aussi une
institution parce que le premier
ministre
il est chef du gouvernement que nous
leur disions aussi vigoureusement au
delà de cette exigence notre confiance
et notre respect
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente oui merci monsieur
le président merci monsieur le premier
ni j'entends bien vous ne voulez pas que
ce débat soit confisquée par des prises
de positions théâtrale comme vous l'avez
dit je peux partager mais monsieur le
premier ministre pour ce faire il faut
aussi entendre et écouter un certain
nombre de propositions qui sont émises
par d'autres que votre force politique
par exemple le ministre de l'intérieur a
annoncé la fin de la clé d'étranglement
très bien mais il n'en demeure pas moins
que le plaquage montera le reste
autorisée
comme d'ailleurs le visage du lb des
carreaux 40 dont nous demandons
l'interdiction les contrôles d'identité
doivent être traçables ici il faut
savoir parler de ça et il faut savoir
écouter les propositions qui sont faites
et j'entends certainement cher j'entends
souvent dans les couloirs des
parlementaires me dire mais madame la
présidente vous avez raison mais vous
comprenez le rapport de force il est
ainsi et ça ne pourrait pas être compris
par tout le monde
je suis désolé mon groupe a fait un
certain nombre
deux propositions sur l'interdiction des
halles bd 40 sur le contrôle dit les
contrôles d'identité abusifs sur la
réforme de l'igpn dont il serait temps
sur laquelle il serait temps de se
pencher sur le rétablissement de la
police de proximité au pays je pense
qu'il serait effectivement temps que
nous ayons un débat serein et
constructif pour répondre à la fois aux
besoins des photos dans notre pays et au
besoin de deux des populations dans les
quartiers particulièrement monsieur le
premier ministre mes chers collègues
notre police et notre gendarmerie
républicaines doivent garantir la paix
civile et protéger nos libertés notre
égalité et notre fraternité
c'est une immense et noble tâche
accomplie dans des conditions de travail
inacceptables qui comporte des risques
nous leur avons unanimement rendu
hommage et on pense encore ramette
merabet et arnaud beltrame a ses héros
et c'est pour cela que c'est
particulièrement insupportable quand on
leur sein certains souvent protégés par
le silence véhicule le poison du racisme
le reconnaître sans le minimiser ne
jamais couvrir de tels propos ou actes
les punir promptement sont une condition
de la confiance à retrouver avec une
grande partie de la jeunesse
c'est un impératif pour la dignité de la
police elle même et pour notre
république
tout commence monsieur le premier
ministre par arrêté avec le déni est un
pas dans ce sens a été fait par le
ministre de l'intérieur et par vous même
encore tout à l'heure et nous nous en
félicitons
mais l' ambiguïté subsiste quand on
entend encore monsieur nunez parler à
nouveau de quelques cas isolés
nous craignons qu'une fois l'émotion
passée on en revienne à l'avant comme
souvent dans le passé
bien entendu je le répète pas de faux
débat en france la police comme
institution n'est pas raciste mais le
racisme et les discriminations n'y sont
pas marginales et les victimes ne sont
pas des exceptions comme par exemple le
quotidien du contrôle au faciès
que comptez vous faire pour encourager
la remontée de tous les faits
répréhensibles
pour contrecarrer la loi du silence et
faire passer la loi de la république
toujours pour valoriser dans les
formations et dans les carrières celles
et ceux qui brillent par leur respect
des valeurs républicaines et de la
dignité humaine et au contraire que
soient mis au ban ceux qui font
l'apologie de la violence ou la pratique
abusivement et qui font l'éloge de la
haine raciste antisémite et homophobe
pour vous répondre la parole est à
monsieur le ministre de l'intérieur le
questionnaire merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur assouline
il n'y a pas de loi du silence il n'y a
que la loi et la police gendarmerie
chaque jour chaque nuit au quotidien
s'engage pour protéger et pour servir la
loi ils le font avec honneur ils le font
avec dignité
ils le font avec un total sens de
l'engagement et je vous le dis et vous
l'avez rappelé il n'y a pas de violence
dans la police il n'y a pas de racisme
policiers mais il existe il existe des
femmes des hommes qui peuvent sauter et
nous devons sur ce sujet être
particulièrement exigeant et je le suis
et je le suis monsieur le sénateur parce
que depuis 20 mois
j'ai l'honneur d'être le premier
défenseur des flics de france
j'ai l'honneur d'être ce défenseur parce
que je sais leur engagement je sais leur
engagement quotidien permanent je sais
leur sens de l'éthique collectif et
c'est parce que je suis le premier
défenseur des flics de france que je
porte monsieur le sénateur cette
exigence d'exemplarité
parce que quand on porte l'uniforme on
porte une parcelle de la république et
canton porte cette parcelle de répliques
on se doit d'être exemplaire
on se doit d'agir dans les tic et c'est
pour cela que j'ai rappelé un certain
nombre de règles
lundi tout en réaffirmant mon engagement
à leurs côtés
j'ai rappelé des règles qui sont des
règles essentielles sur tous ces sujets
j'ai rappelé monsieur le sénateur les
règles qui doivent prévaloir lors des
contrôles d'identité j'ai rappelé
monsieur le sénateur l'exigence aussi
que nous devons comme n'est pour
combattre tout acte de racisme et je les
dis chaque son chaque fait dès lors
qu'une enquête établi qu'ils sont
avérées doit faire l'objet d'une
sanction administrative immédiate
l'année dernière
30 faits de racisme ont été signalés à
l'igpn et ont fait l'objet d'une enquête
judiciaire
huit ont été classées sans suite 22 ont
été transmis au procureur de la
république dans ce cadre là monsieur le
sénateur je souhaite que dorénavant dès
lors qu'il ya transmission aux
magistrats et qu'on a les éléments qui
caractérisent une enquête qui mérite
justement cela il y à une suspension
une suspension administrative qui est
d'une mesure de protection de l'ensemble
de la police et ces mesures mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs sont fait
justement pour protéger l'honneur de nos
policiers l'honneur de nos gendarmes et
je sais qu'ils sont pleinement engagés
en cela monsieur le président monsieur
le premier ministre il ya quelques
semaines je vous ai entendu parler
d'écroulement et ce terme mois ne
m'avait pas choquer vous parlait alors
d'un écroulement économique et social
aujourd'hui la menace qui est devant
nous c'est celle d'un écroulement
civique
comment quelques jours avez vous pu
laisser l'état autant reculer des
manifestations interdites autorisé mais
surtout surtout des minorités agissantes
qui sous prétexte de l'antiracisme
veulent propager la haine vis-à-vis de
nos forces de l'ordre veulent fracturé
notre modèle républicain
quand une garde des sceaux s'immisce
dans une affaire privée privée alors que
elle doit être le garant de
l'indépendance de la justice
c'est évidemment l'état de droit qui est
fragilisée quand en retour de cette
invitation imprudente
elle reçoit est un camouflet calculer
c'est toute la république est humilié
quand votre ministre de l'intérieur
déclare que l'émotion doit dépasser la
règle de droit
c'est ici mes chers collègues que nous
votons la loi c'est évidemment là aussi
une fragilisation de l'état de droit
c'est la porte ouverte à la loi de la
jungle et c'est aussi la possibilité
compromise demain de la concorde civile
et quand le même ministre fait cette
trouvaille cette acrobatie sémantique de
préjugés a viré qui va livrer
policiers et nos gendarmes à la
présomption de culpabilité c'est
évidemment la présomption d'innocence
qui est défigurée alors oui nous devons
être intraitables avec et contre le
racisme
vous avez raison mais sans tomber dans
les pièges les pièges de ce qui nous
tente qui veulent communautariser la
france qu'ils veulent désigner notre
pays comme éternellement coupable
monsieur le premier ministre
les policiers les gendarmes sont notre
bouclier vous ne pouvez pas nous dire
ici avec des proclamations de respect et
estime qu' ils sont effectivement pour
nous une protection
vous devez leur prouver reprenez vous à
votre compte l'expression du ministre
l'intérieur
reprenez vous à votre compte
l'initiative de votre garde des sceaux
pour vous répondre l'apparent le cas
monsieur le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le président je connais notre
maîtrise du langage et d'ailleurs elle
est souvent admiré c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous sachant précis je suis
surpris par un certain nombre d
expression que vous avez utilisé dans
votre question et que j'ai essayé de
noter pour ne pas pour ne pas exposer à
la même critique que celle que je
pourrais éventuellement formulée vous
avez dit monsieur le président
retailleau que la garde des sceaux avait
voulu s'immiscer dans une affaire privée
il n'en est rien monsieur le président
retailleau le fait que le ministre de la
justice propose de recevoir
vous allez me dire que non pas la
famille mais le comité qui s'est
constituée que je ne connais pas moi qui
existent pour avoir un échange sur ou
nous en sommes
sur des faits qui sont anciens vous le
savez sur une instruction qui est lente
vous le déplorez comme moi comme moi ne
constitue pas une immixtion dans la
procédure
en aucune façon en aucune façon il est
vrai que si à l'invitation d'un membre
de la famille la garde des sceaux donné
une instruction individuelle alors nous
serions dans quelque chose qui n'est pas
légal et il ne vous a pas échappé que la
garde des sceaux avait à juste titre
indiqué qu'il n'en était pas question qu
il ne saurait en être question
je crois donc monsieur le président à
taillon que en vous plaçant sur ce
terrain vous vous ne décrivait pas
réellement la position de la garde des
sceaux son expression et la volonté
qu'elle a affirmé
de la même façon vous fait le reproche
au ministre de l'intérieur de ce que en
évoquant dans une interview le concept
dont je reconnais volontiers qu'ils
peuvent avoir la forme d'un oxymore de
soupçons avérés dans une interview on
répond on se placerait en dehors des
règles de la république
mais monsieur le président retailleau si
vous pensez vraiment cela alors je
crains et je sais que ce n'est pas vrai
que vous ignoriez la pratique
administrative actuelle car que se
passe-t-il monsieur le président
retailleau quand des faits qui n'ont pas
donné lieu à une déclaration de
culpabilité sont susceptibles de
troubler l'exercice du service public
l'autorité administrative peut et
souvent doit prendre des mesures avant
la déclaration de culpabilité des
mesures de suspension par exemple ça
n'est en rien une méconnaissance de la
présomption d'innocence que vous semblez
déploré c'est de bonne administration
ce n'est pas moi qui les ai inventées et
ça n'est pas ministre de l'intérieur il
inventait c'est la pratique constante
constante reçu le président retailleau
dans l'administration et c'est une bonne
pratique et je l'assumé
car lorsque des faits encore une fois
sans que la justice n'ait pu déterminer
si les auteurs présumés sont coupables
lorsque des faits sont de nature à créer
une telle impossibilité d'exercer
sereinement le service public alors
l'autorité administrative est dans son
droit lorsqu'elle suspend les agents
c'est ça qu'a voulu dire le ministre de
l'intérieur il a parfaitement bien fait
et puisque vous et moi nous sommes
attachés à la république puisque vous et
moi nous sommes attachés à la république
je préférerais que vous comme moi nous
expliquions cela parce que ça n'est pas
simple c'est vrai mais que nous
expliquions cela à nos concitoyens qui
ne comprennent parfaitement plutôt que
de feindre un autre sens à ce qui a été
dit voilà ce que je vais vous dire
monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état le 27 mai dernier soit
une semaine après la publication par
zélande 7 d'une étude sur les usages de
l'hydroxyde chloroquine votre ministère
a interdit l'usagé en a interdit l'usagé
dans le traitement du coc u19 cette
interdiction faisait suite au degré du
25 mars qui défend des aux patients au
libre aux médecins libéraux de prescrire
cette molécule à leurs patients on sait
ce qu'il est advenu de cette étude qui a
été désavoué d'abord par les éditeurs du
land set et ensuite par trois de ces
quatre auteurs cette étude était en
réalité une vaste farce dont les
scientifiques les soignant les patients
et votre gouvernement en ont été les
dindons
c'est triste on me rétorquera que
d'autres études n'ont pas pu démontrer
c'est efficace et de l'efficacité de
cette molécule
mais la vérité que les protocoles mis en
concurrence sont tellement divergent
qu'il est impossible d'affirmer
aujourd'hui que cette molécule est
efficace ou pas même s'il semble que les
patients traités dès lors dépistage et
dont l'état ne nécessite pas une
hospitalisation s'en sortent
majoritairement mieux une chose est
absolument certaine en revanche seuls
les médecins sont abda proscrit à
prescrire le protocole qui leur semble
le mieux convenir à leurs patients
votre gouvernement a peut-être un goût
certain pour les ordonnances moi je
préfère celle qui porte un caducée ma
question est simple dames la secrétaire
d'état n'est this ne serait-il pas temps
de reconnaître qu'il y a eu de
l'emballement dans cette affaire est de
redonner aux médecins la liberté de
prescrire merci pour vous répondre
d'abord le cas madame la secrétaire
d'état revenue misé solidarité de la
santé
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur ou perd la mise en avant des
mécanismes d'action de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine a légitimement soulevé
beaucoup d'espoir ces dernières semaines
et ce au plus fort de la période
épidémique que nous venons de vivre de
nombreux de travaux de recherche vous
l'avez vous en avez cité quelques-uns
ont été menées pour tenter d'analyser
son efficacité et son innocuité dans le
traitement de la maladie kovy de 19
le ministre et l'ensemble du
gouvernement était transparent tous les
efforts ont été mis en place afin de
trouver des réponses rigoureuses et
scientifique à ces questions à ce show à
ce jour les travaux de recherche menés
n'ont pas réussi à démontrer avec un
niveau de preuve suffisants l'efficacité
de l'hydraulique le recul chez les
malades hospitalisés ou dans les formes
les plus simples par ailleurs de
nombreuses études ont montré à montrer
des effets secondaires connus et
renforcé dans certaines associations
médicamenteuses deux travaux
scientifiques issus d'auteur similaires
ont dû être retirés en raison de
questions sur l'intégrité scientifique
de ces travaux et nous le déplorons
néanmoins l'ensemble des études
rassemblées à ce jour sur la question de
lido de l'utilisation de l'hydro de
cycle rockin dans le traitement de la
maladie qu'ovide ne justifie pas son
utilisation en pratique courante
compte tenu de la décroissance
progressive de l'épidémie cette question
devient aujourd'hui moins urgente et
certaines études se poursuivent encore
actuellement
enfin concernant la liberté de
prescription
cette liberté n'a jamais été entravée je
rappelle que la liberté de prescription
n'a jamais été totale l'ordre des
médecins l'a encore rappelé récemment
l'article 8 du code de déontologie
médicale précise que le médecin est
libre de ses prescriptions dans les
limites fixées par la loi et compte tenu
des données acquises
de la science je vous remercie merci la
parole les machores notre collègue
martial bourquin
pour le groupe socialiste or pardonnez
moi mon cher collègue chez monsieur
opère bénéficier de plus de 20 secondes
pardonnez moi madame la secrétaire
d'état
je suis parlementaire mais je suis aussi
médecin et s'est levé s'est quelquefois
s'éloigner des certitudes et
s'interroger et il ya des chiffres
intercond incontestable quand tes
certitudes et ces chiffres sont ceux de
votre ministère alors qu on hospitalise
les gens pour les mêmes raisons en
france le taux de décès chez les
personnes hospitalisées est de 3,1 pour
cent à marseille et de 17,2 pour cent au
niveau national voilà qui devrait à
toulouse - vous interrogez madame la
secrétaire d'état
monsieur le ministre dans le cadre de la
reprise progressive des cours à l'école
votre dispositif sport santé et culture
civisme
deux aces de ces entend offrir des
activités ducati sur le temps scolaire
ce dispositif se veut une réponse à la
crise sanitaire et au contrôle et
contraintes du protocole qui entraîne
des conséquences très lourdes sur le
nombre d'élèves prise en charge
nous savons tous que l'absence de
reprise scolaire pour une part non
négligeable et constater et regretter
par tous car les dangers de la
déscolarisation physiques sont immenses
les dégâts seraient irréversibles si la
majorité des enfants ne retrouvait pas
le chemin de l'école avant septembre
prochain
hier encore le maire de besançon me
demander d'intercéder auprès de vous
pour un desserrement du protocole sur ce
pôle sanitaire dans la mesure où les
parcs sont ouverts les écolos
aujourd'hui ne le sont pas totalement
cependant monsieur le ministre ce
dispositif deux aces de ses douze
interroge car l'ouverture de l'école aux
intervenants extérieurs pendant le temps
scolaire doit rester une exception mais
surtout ce dispositif nous inquiète car
de nombreux maires nous appelle tous les
jours pour nous faire part de leurs
difficultés matérielles humaines et
surtout financière ces nouvelles charges
sont une fois de plus assumée par les
collectivités locales
et ce ne sont pas les 110 euros par jour
par groupes d'élèves de 15 qui seront
suffisants
nous sommes dans le temps scolaire et
c'est à l'état d'assumer ses charges
nous sénateurs as enceinte où est l
ancien président qui précédait donc le
président larcher jules ferry nous ne
voulons pas supprimer la position
égalité égalité de la divise
républicaine qui se trouve au fronton de
nos écoles
depuis la loi du 14 juillet 1881 liberté
égalité fraternité
car je sais que c'est dispositif
insuffisamment financé sera surtout en
zone rurale et parfois en zone urbaine
source d'inégalité la sollicitation des
finances locales ne serait devenir le
moyen ordinaire de mise en oeuvre
budgétaire de votre gouvernement les
collectivités locales vont payer très
lourdement déjà les conséquences de la
crise une question et une seule monsieur
le ministre
quelles sont vos intentions sur la
pérennité et le financement futur des
deux s ii c merci et bénéficier des
secondes jules ferry pour vous répondre
la parole est aux ministres de
l'éducation nationale et de la jeunesse
merci monsieur le président je découvre
que votre longévité est encore plus
grande que ce que je croyais et grâce
aux sénateurs gros plan sur le sénateur
européen
merci pour pour cette question qui est
extrêmement importante dans un contexte
qui est très particulier il ya plusieurs
points d'accord entre ce que vous avez
pu dire est ce que je pourrais vous
répondre d'abord l'importance du sport
et de la culture ne perdons pas le sens
de cette mesure si nous avons élaboré ce
dispositif de zeste de cesser pour
promouvoir quelque chose qui je crois
fait consensus dans notre société c'est
à dire plus d'activité sportive plus
d'activités culturelles plus et à
l'éducation à la santé et au civisme
aussi dans notre pays et donc c'est
l'occasion d'avancer sur cette question
je rappelle que le dispositif n'a rien
d'obligatoire donc senna en rien une
contrainte les les communes peuvent y
adhérer si elles le veulent et
d'ailleurs plus de 1000 communes l'ont
fait en france y compris je crois aux
neuf dans votre beau département du
doubs donc il y a réellement une
positivité de contractualisation entre
l'état et les communes et je crois que
c'est ce type de relation que justement
les communes appelle souvent de leurs
voeux on dit parfois 110 euros vous
l'avez dit pourra par jour et par élève
ça n'est pas assez je rappelle que c'est
un forfait autrement
même trois heures correspondent à ses
110 euros pour pour 15 élèves par
ailleurs l'éducation nationale
participent des professeurs peuvent
peuvent participer donc il y à toute une
série de cas de figure où en réalité ça
peut ne rien coûter à la commune cela ne
doit pas nous faire perdre de vue les
objectifs de fond qui sont d'arriver à
ce que nous ayons une vision complète du
temps de l'enfant au moins du lundi au
vendredi si ce n'est davantage entre le
temps scolaire et le temps périscolaire
et oui je crois qu'il est bon qu'il n'y
ait pas de cloison étanche entre les
deux c'est évidemment de temps
différents mais il doit y avoir une
articulation quand un enfant fait de la
musique le mercredi c'est évidemment bon
pour ses apprentissages le reste de la
semaine donc l'alliance collectivités
locales l'éducation nationale n'est en
rien une remise en cause du caractère
national du service public nous y sommes
tous très attachés
mais c'est au contraire signes de
coopération et bien entendu nous devons
dans le futur progresser encore en
matière d'activités sportives et
culturelles
enfin je serai sur la même longueur
d'onde que vous sur l'allégement du
protocole sanitaire
nous y travaillons avec le premier
ministre nous avons un conseil de
défense vendredi pour aller dans ce sens
rappelons que nous avons voulu à tout
prix ce déconfinement scolaire qu'il a
fallu le courage du président de la
république pour le décidé le 11 mai
aujourd'hui tout le monde voit que
c'était la bonne décision et d'une
certaine façon c'est un hommage que vous
nous rendez en nous demandant
d'accélérer
merci merci monsieur 2010 pour la
précision historique
jules ferry n'a été que trois semaines
président du sénat vous voyez que je
joue les prolongations
voilà
[Musique]